hi my name is Emily Cochran and I'm the
writer producer and supporting actress
for a film called the stolen the stolen
was shot in New Zealand and was funded
out of the UK Germany New Zealand
obviously and a little bit out of the
States and it was a really really tricky
thing to put together financially so
I've been asked by film courage to talk
to you about film funding so the first
thing I'd like to say as a creative
person who had to go into film funding
to fund my own film was it sucks I can't
really express how much I dislike it I
really do I think if you're a creative
which you may very well be you might be
a director or a writer trying to get
your own project off the ground it's
probably the last thing you want to
think about and frankly it is a very
very different skill set but let me see
if I can help you a bit
so the first thing to have a think about
is sales agents sales agents are crucial
to your financial package in fact
without a sales agent and without their
projections it's really hard to move
forward and to getting a film funded so
the reason for this is that investors
have very little security when they
invest in a film they can't really say
whether it will ever make anything
because it's an unknown quantity however
a sales agent may be able to offer
projections based upon similar films
they've sold or films with similar
actors in them and that kind of thing
and if they're respected it does give
the investor a lot of comfort so how
does a sales agent assess your project
well the first thing they look at is
obviously the script and they look at
the genre and in some cases if it's for
instance a horror or a martial arts film
the genre itself and if it's well
written could be enough for them to give
projections upon because it doesn't
necessarily have to have any named
actors in it but generally sadly you do
need the actors and the actors are
really what they base their projections
on if I'm honest so it'll keep coming
back to that the actors the actors the
actors who is in it it's like everything
goes backwards from the screen so how do
you get the actors it is a whole
different tutorial however what I would
say is let me give you some advice if
your grandmother's second cousins dog
knows Brad Pitt please get friendly with
that dog and if you can get something
via the dog - Brad Pitt then do it
because it is so hard to attach name
Talent particularly when you're a
first-timer
you need to pull out all the stops work
out all your connections no matter how
tenuous and give it a go my advice is
always be polite don't be too pushy some
actors are really responsive
to an outside connection others are not
and they really want you to go through
the agent the problem is the bigger the
actor the more blockage from the agent
because they're being offered so much
stuff and obviously the agent is
filtering and trying to get the best
deals and your film even though your
script may be really great for that
actor might be too risky you're a
first-timer they've never heard of you
there's lots and lots of reasons so
whatever you can do try and get that to
an actor maybe a different way if you
can run the back door the other advice
is just write really good parts just
think about that and maybe offer it to
an actor who doesn't normally play those
kind of roles and they might just find
it an interesting thing to do and take
it I would also advise going via
managers and the states because the
managers are looking much more at the
overall career of the actor as opposed
to just you know what they're making and
you know American agents are well pretty
hard-nosed and they will they would just
curl you out they are obligated to give
the script to the actor but they don't
have to give it to them for 12 months
and they could also say anything they
like while they pass it over so just
bear that in mind
so say you get to that point you've got
your actor
you've got your great script you've
maybe got your storyboards you've got
some professional team members and
you've got sales estimates what next
you can begin to piece together your
film finance plan film finance can come
from all different sources and I would
advise really doing some research a lot
of it is grunt work
so one of the easiest sources of film
funding it comes from government tax
breaks or tax credits or tax grants and
they can be given just for shooting a
film in the area and this can be your
state if you're in America it can be an
in Canada it can be your town it can be
your country and don't be scared of
going outside your own country as well
because you might find that there are
more or higher rates of tax breaks
outside and if your film isn't too
low-budget
it could really work for you or you
could look at doing a co-production
where you tap into a tax break in one
country and a tax break in another and
they could fit together it begins to get
a little bit complicated paperwork wise
because you have to do official
co-productions but sometimes you don't
in the stolen we didn't we did an
unofficial co-production with Germany so
it is possible that's the first thing I
would look there you can get between
twenty to forty percent of your budget
just from tax breaks so get online look
at all of the Commission's everywhere
and see what they're offering in that
area and if it means you have to move to
move your project to Australia or Canada
or you know just Connecticut then do it
okay that will be the simplest thing to
do obviously taking into account having
to hire a local crew and all that anyway
so that's the first thing the second
thing is there are grants often given
separate grants so equity grants given
by film Commission's in Britain it's the
BFI the British Film Institute in New
Zealand for instance it's the New
Zealand Film Commission
and most countries have a Film
Commission of some sort and you can
apply now this is really really
difficult to get this money then
normally as a hell of a lot of criteria
they have to take a lot of boxes because
it's government money so they have to
have certain things in place before they
can give it to you and often it is
leaning towards non-commercial projects
so if you have a commercial project it
might be really difficult to get money
but I always say put in an application
and then forget about it if you get the
money from them and you get on to that
system fantastic because once you're in
their system you can do really well out
of it so the next thing is I get private
money there are lots of different
options there are bank
well banking I guess is different than
private but I would say bank gaps which
are difficult to get unless you have
done pre-sales
and a lot of the first time is watching
this will not get pre-sales pre-sales
have got more and more and more
difficult to get and a lot of banks just
don't want to that they're incredibly
risk-averse and they do not want to risk
not getting their money back so they
like to be assured that when the film is
finished there will be a sale it's very
hard to do at the moment so banks are
difficult but there are private
companies that do gap
and when I say gap that is money that
comes out in first position
with nobody else okay so it's got to
come out first and often that can be
between 10 and 20 percent so it's worth
that if you can get 20 for sure but
there'll be caveats
again Google gap financing and see what
you find the same companies will
probably if you are lucky enough to have
a presale they will also cashflow
pre-sales moving on there is other types
of funding in Britain there are there is
a
tax break for investors which is
different from the government tax break
for filmmakers and that's called an
enterprise investment scheme and that
means that the person investing gets a
30%
well tax break on on their own tax bill
and there could be similar things like
that and wherever you're living it's
worth looking into this is a really good
thing because it is a risky business for
a private investor to put money in so
that if they know that guaranteed some
think back like a tax break it becomes a
little bit easier to convince them if
you do tap into this and you're
fortunate enough to either find a fund
that's already up and running and can
assess your project and put money and or
you find a private individual who's
willing to do it you can really get a
big chunk of your budget you know I I
would say 30% in my case I probably got
close to 50% of my budget from private
individuals who went into an enterprise
investment scheme and and a startup
Enterprise Investment Scheme which is
another form of tax break which was
wonderful really really helpful the
other forms of funding are there are
just straight equity funds out there
many in America there are a few and the
UK and there's quite a few in Germany as
well their money has come from venture
capitalists they've come from private
individuals who just really like film
it's it's difficult but they are funds
and you should just again Google
research really really research and look
up film equity funds okay that's
different to film tax breaks it's
different to gap funding because equity
is is a different animal they take a
proportion of the movie
one of the other wonderful options if
you're lucky enough to meet them is a
wealthy person now they're really hard
to find unless you're particularly
well-connected and if you're not well
connected but you know somebody who is
and they might be interested in in doing
film you know make a proposal to them
say look do you think you could raise
fun funds for me on my movie for
Commission for a credit whatever you
need to offer them and and we can become
a team it is worth finding these people
if you can and prefer ending them and
really looking at a business deal the
only thing that I would say is that if
you're talking to a private investor
really really be as honest as possible
about returns about the risk and all of
that because you don't want it to bite
you on the ass later it would be a
nightmare and it's also really sad for
the rest of us who are being honest
about whether the film's gonna make
money or not because if they lose their
money they will never invest in a film
again so think about your future career
now a lot of wealthy people who may be
wealthy from a different industry might
get involved with the film purely
because it's a film it's interesting
they might like the subject matter they
may like the actor they might like yeah
the genre they might like where it's
being shot it might be meaningful to
them in some way and it may not actually
be about money
but ultimately you really want to try
and get their money back and the other
point that I should make is that if you
do get a private individual try and
ensure that in the waterfall in their
finance and the finance plan that they
come out in a reasonably high position
so they're not last on the list because
that that's not great so from a private
individual you could get 10% of your
budget you could get more you could get
five who knows but there are other
options which I will tell you about so
the
option is to go and do a deal with a
post-production house or a equipment
house and do in kind investment or they
may actually do physical cash investment
for a movie and in a way that's their
way of discounting the their services
however it can come in in a version of
an investment and that could give you up
to 5% of your budget also another little
known and little utilized option is a
music deal so there are companies out
there who will take the rights to your
soundtrack obviously it has to be
original music and they will give you
money for it upfront or they might give
it to you when you're in post often it's
only approximately 1% of your budget but
it's really useful because it's cash
they don't come out in the waterfall
they literally just take the the
soundtrack rights and then they go away
so the other option which I've left to
last which the main reason being is is
that it is less and less likely these
days is a distribution deal so if you
have a movie that is very attractive and
has a really well-known actor or it's a
particular genre that's very hip and
that distributor believes that they can
make money out of it you make it a
pre-sale so they may commit to buying
the movie before the film was made and
in that case you can then finance a
foreign bank or a private investor and
that could be multi territory or it
could just be one territory you have to
be very careful about how many
territories they take for what money
because if you've got other investors
involved you have to be sure that
they're still getting a piece of the pie
when they come out so those are the
options you need to get on Google you
need to
start looking this stuff up and it's a
lot of grunt work okay but I'm sure you
can do it
so lastly remember film funding doesn't
stop once you've raised the money
unfortunately
investors are gonna know what's going on
with their money all the way through the
process they're going to want reports
they're going to want to know what's
happening and boy when you have finished
that film and it starts being shown to
buyers they're going to want to know
what the results are and unfortunately
you're probably going to sweat because
if they're not selling the film is not
selling for what you expected it to
where it's not selling it can be really
stressful even though you may have
warned the investors of the risks they
may not have really comprehended them or
done they don't want to hear it and that
can be a lot of sweat so remember it
doesn't stop this is why I said it sucks
because it doesn't matter that you raise
the money and then you get to make the
film and you have that great time on set
and you really enjoy everything and then
you get to show it to people you've
still got people to answer to at the end
of it my final word is if you by any
chance get offered by a studio to be
taken under their wing and they pay for
the whole lot and just give you a fee
dear God take it okay just take it
forget about the independent thing just
take the studio deal okay you don't want
to be thinking about this stuff alright
really try and get away from it as
quickly as you can so just think of this
smaller movie as your stepping stone to
being looked after later if you can okay
now if any of you out there are thinking
about funding your own film and you
think that I really know what I'm doing
please don't come to me I'm not gonna
help you fund your film because I hate
it okay but watch the stolen